so the first thing to do was gain the
weight and get big as big as I could
your dad
he's a hero
if I don't believe I'm Chris no one else
is going to believe it I need to figure
out how he talks and then I need to
figure out how he walks and the only way
to do that is to get as big as he was I
mean I sat across from his father Wayne
who just said you know you know you're
half the size of my son and there's no
you know and you don't sound a goddamn
thing like him so I don't know how
you're going to do it he put on like 44
pounds which is just Monumental we kept
hearing about that like have you seen
Bradley he's as big as an ox and can
break people and bench press a thousand
pounds and so uh we're all anticipating
meeting him and I don't know if you
remember this like we were shooting in
Morocco Bradley gets out of the van
everyone's like oh God here he comes
this is it like and gets off the van the
van's like shaking from you getting up
you have like you have he's enormous
like his neck was like a hamstring and
you're like marching over the the accent
gun on his back and he walks up and goes
you guys seen that movie Frozen